so to help would you reach him hand if
you have your calculator here today
hands up hands up okay not everyone
hands down but enough boss once you get
it out please if you don't have that pop
it out of your bag and I take most of
you have a calculator a similar to this
if you don't I'm going to draw some
pictures on the board to help you see
beyond the symbols that I'm after so
there are a few particular buttons that
are going to be really important to us
okay so I'm looking right in the middle
up here in this grave hard with the
little buttons and there are two lungs
that I'm particularly interested in okay
so they look like this and they're right
next to each other you can even draw
these in your book if you like so that
you will know what you are referring to
in case you forget in the future so
these are the two particular buttons i'm
interested in these little brain ones
and one of them has this square root
symbol and then there's like a blank
underneath because you get to fit in
another right just above the square root
button you can see written I think it's
probably a yellow on your calculator
there is the cube root right how do you
get to that thing about how do you get
the other [ __ ] yeah so for any of those
buttons if you want to get to the theme
of it shift will do it and beside it
you've got this guy what do you reckon
that's about very good yeah so you're
sweating it and I think um in fact yeah
after Bob here I'm actually um I'll
actually not give it myself enough space
I think it's right there is the X cubed
button do you have that so this will
square a number for us and this will
cubed yes
if you want to not write to this entry
the one on the right yeah that's right
you've got lots of different options I'd
only get too confused so we'll just look
at these three buttons first so now what
I want you to do is just to get a feel
for this right let's have a look at some
of these results here I can just go to
our my keypad and then I can give the
square button and you can see it comes
in index form there after going in the
top right and of course you can hit
equals and you get the answer you expect
right does that make sense remember a
few minutes ago I told you that 11
squared was 121 we can check that right
11 hit the square button and you should
get your answer back okay so now you can
see if you can use that in Reverse as
well let's just verify we just said if i
clear all of that press the square root
button after this one and then you'll
see on your arm on your display it will
literally give you a little box I want
to display it will look like this and
you can put a number in there so I'm
going to type 121 all right that's now
underneath the square root button so it
looks like this and if you hit equals
fingers crossed if your calculators
worth the money to pay for you should
get 11 fantastic
ok now the same way remember I said to
you and pulled out of a hat of the cube
root of 343 I said it was seven can you
test it for me yeah 343 so we're going
to go shift shift press the square root
button then you type in 343 and thank
goodness i can still through numbers ok
so so now you can see how it works
that's the basic skills yes the squared
three squared three Jimmy do you need to
the power of three yeah so there's a
button above the square root button that
looks like that it's got a three instead
okay if yours looks a bit different
that's okay it might be hiding somewhere
else now remember when we did our review
questions i had actually all different
kinds of powers just while we're all
doing our calculators together you can
see me recording this out a second ago
beside the x square button i think you
have this fun do you see that one that
one yeah so now you can pick a number
let's all do five for instance okay five
if you press this button key are it lets
you choose the power you don't have to
do two or three you can pick any power
you'd like right so if i press that what
power would you like one take a do two
or three but we've already got buttons
for those i'm going to go to ten for
this nice and being i can't do that my
hand and it adds me a suitably logical
bomb now if you put in a really really
big number the numbers start to get a
bit crazy and if you put a big enough
number let's say I'm gonna put in I put
in 5 to the power of a million and said
to me math era because his brain his
brain is no baby that's all right there
oh yeah it's right question 1 point 6 15
587 134 times yeah now what are you
Catholic yes so we're going to get to
how to move the piano as a bit later on
but I think you've got that important
skills that you
which is mainly these three okay alright
so one last thing before I set you on
the exercise would you please draw for
me a table I'd like you to have two
colors and one two three four five rows
would you do that for me now be the last
thing we did together then I set your
work you can do very well might be doing
statistics yea yea marry some guys yes
excavation box mean something really
really interesting i can't wait to show
you what the hell okay so i asked you to
draw for me is lasting a [ __ ] table 2
columns fibro
and the reason why we're doing this is
just so that you can see how all of
these different pieces of mass that you
know they fit together it is beautiful
hole okay so like a hominin ami a whole
thing together I'm kind of think of a
suitable see it but for whole not like
Paul anyway the bigger one of them now
operations my functions you know loads
of operations can someone tell me what's
an operation i can put between two
numbers anyone an easy one yes Peppa
multiplication ok I'm going to put that
in the second row you'll see why I say
um if i multiply right so for example i
could multiply by seven every operation
has what we call its opposite of fancy
word is interest ok that will undo the
operation what's the opposite of
multiplication division sign on the
right divine so x 7/7 they kind of
collide with each other and kids alike
right give me another operation another
operation that you know simple one
someone else yes ok so modest well this
is the opposite of what's right adding
and subtracting so i'm gonna put them
right at the top if i add a number
that's usually what most people becoming
the first one
we've got a lot that's okay our for
example if I + 7 x + 7 the opposite of
that is subtract and subtract by the way
just as a little minor thing minus minus
is actually not not this thing here it's
not a verb it's an object there so you
should say i'm going to subtract 7
rather than a minus 7 minus is trying to
remember the symbol anyway that's a
minor ok now we've just learned new
operations and they're opposites in new
operations and their offices so the
first new operation was swearing so if I
wrote 7 squared we've got this right
here right the opposite of squaring is
this guy the square root
if I did seven squared that takes me to
49 doesn't it seven times seven I can
undo the squaring by using the square
root the square root of 49 that will
take you right back where you started ok
and the last one we learnt tying it all
up and lastly not is Gibby right so I
could say for example 7 cubed which we
did on our calculator before and check
that I wasn't just making it up right 7
cubed is 343 big number but I can go
back to the number i started me if I use
the opposite the cube root so for
example the cube root of 343 sorry I
didn't make my table big enough ok